what i think is so fascinating about
this is one i agree with you and think
that the investment strategy is
incredibly compelling given the macro
environment the asset itself and then uh
kind of your age risk profile and just
the long time horizon uh but it's no
different than some of the timeless
investing advice that others have heard
so like warren buffett for example talks
all the time about if you buy a great
asset the best time to sell is never
right just hold it literally forever uh
and so uh stacking sats may not be the
same vernacular that he would use uh a
digital decentralized currency may not
be the thing he's interested in but if
it ends up in hindsight being a great
asset and people buy it and they hold it
forever it's no different than that
timeless investment advice that he's
been telling his shareholders and kind
of the public markets forever right
yeah i mean
in a warren buffett style approach like
the the markets are overpriced um and
what i'm what i'm using as my you know
as my currency or my my savings so so
i'm not investing at the moment i'm just
i'm just simply saving um because
because you know i'll wait for the
market to correct uh in bitcoin terms
you know you know when looking at
everything um look at any chart over the
last five years or last three years uh
in bitcoin terms and i think uh that's
that's the truth that's what's occurring
and obviously um you're not going to see
a 200 compounded annual growth rate of
like forever that's not that's just not
sustainable
but i think um you know bitcoin is going
to see this decade at least 100x you
know appreciation maybe you know maybe a
little less maybe a little more but um
we're just getting started with this
thing um you know in terms of global
adoption if you look at global wealth
it's it's so it's extremely early and
you know you know i respect people that
that can can make it trading in and out
every day um but ultimately that's just
something that um i for the most part
stay away from and i just you know i'm
going to produce value and i'm going to
store that value and what i think
is going to protect the best i've got my
brother john here with me john what
questions you got yeah thanks for doing
this dylan um i love how you talk about
your 20 years old so you can withstand
the volatility and uh look at that
future growth but a lot of our followers
are also similar to you as uh the
younger demographic and everything can
you talk about your joint your journey
to bitcoin and how you found it and then
how you found your um and how you go
about working at bitcoin magazine
yeah um totally honestly part of my
journey was uh basically like podcasts
like this um and just like the free
education that's available online um
you know i i went to college for one
year uh studied business economics but i
i dropped out because i was learning
more on twitter uh and reading books
that people recommended um and so i
think for anyone that's kind of
interested in this space but more
broadly you know um in the in the you
know digital economy um it's you don't
need a degree you don't need
like the credentialism of the past um
and there's so many ways to just kind of
make it out there today on the internet
um and to learn and to reach out to
people um you know like i i learned a
lot about bitcoin from watching the and
listening to the pomp podcast while i
worked a day job right so um and like
you know various other ones but um it
was something i stumbled upon bitcoin
late high school um while i was just
trying to figure out investing um and i
just logged onto twitter and just read
what i thought smart people had to say
about it and so um that was more
valuable for me than listening to my to
my boomer professor over over zoom call
when they sent us some from kovitz so
you know it was a no-brainer for me like
hey like i'm just gonna drop out and and
i uh i just worked a regular job for for
like six six months and uh you know got
a dm basically for uh for a job
opportunity which was you know maybe a
stroke alone maybe not but you know it
turned into something something that i
hope will last
nice so is it true that bitcoin made you
drop out of college
yeah yeah for sure um i i mean i tweeted
about it and told my friends and stuff
like hey like i'm dropping out and
they're like just to work a job to stack
sass and like what's sats and why are
you dropping out like what are you crazy
um and like i honestly did it like that
i read i read a couple books that kind
of melted my brain like like the
sovereign individual i read and then
prices tomorrow by jeff booth um
basically like how the internet was
basically putting the cost of education
and learning things to zero um and that
you know the credentialism of the
industrial age was was dissipating with
the internet and so for me i was like
okay why am i studying finance and
economics uh learning keynesian
economics stuff i don't believe like
they're telling me hey inflation's two
percent and i was like no it's not
they're like yeah cpi says so and it was
like that was the answer i was like okay
well
i don't think this is too valuable for
me so
um yeah i just there's something like
alright i'm gonna drop um this is and i
got a lot of pushback from it um
initially my parents were a little
skeptical but now they're i think
they're fully orange killed and they're
stacking themselves and and you know
they agree with my decision now but um i
definitely was was not like the
traditional path per se
you may not know that i used to say this
i'm going to go ahead and say it i feel
like we're safe now the virus is
spreading that's what happens it is uh
basically like bitcoin used to be
described as this mind virus right like
once you learn about it you just can't
stop thinking about it you can't start
stop seeing the world in a different way
then you start to tell people and
explain it and it just spreads through a
uh a group of people in terms of the
education and the knowledge um and kind
of that that red pill that orange pill
uh type thing talk a little bit about
you you mentioned uh kind of like not
getting the formal education and the
keynesian economics and and i actually
think it's a really interesting point
that most older people probably don't
think uh from this perspective but if
you go to college and they teach you
something that either was true about the
world in the past but no longer is true
or two is a way to look at the world
that uh you don't agree with in some
weird way not only are you wasting your
time or money but on top of that you're
actually having information put into
your brain that ends up being inaccurate
and therefore could be incredibly
detrimental and so dropping out in some
weird way uh is a better way to pursue
knowledge than actually staying there
and getting that information right
yeah totally i mean they were they were
teaching me they were they were bringing
up you know textbooks from i don't even
know when the 70s or 80s and they were
saying hey this is the phillips curve
and this is inflation and this is
employment and they have this
relationship and i was like no they
don't look at that like i mean look at
the data and and it was like it was just
weird things like that it was just like
you know that was anecdotal but it was
like
you know maybe if i was an engineer or
some or something or i needed to go to
school it would be different but i was
studying like finance and economics and
and i was i was literally listening to
podcasts more than i was that i was
attending in classes and doing homework
and so i was like all right screw this
like and i dropped out and i literally
picked up a manual labor job it's like
it wasn't too fun but i listened to i
literally listened to eight hours of
bitcoin podcast today for like six seven
months um and i got i think i got the
best education in my life like it turned
into a legit job opportunity i get to
hang on twitter all day and and write
about bitcoin and financial markets um
you know it's it's something that like
and that's completely self-taught over
the internet and like i'm not not like
bragging or anything i'm just like
trying to say that it's you know the
cost of a lot of this information um and
access to it and you have some of the
smart people in the world sharing their
thoughts for free on these platforms
like
it that's something that you know
college i don't think i don't think can
keep up with right like i was i was
sitting at home and in march april may
after they sent everyone home for covid
and i was i was paying to to have these
boomers on a zoom call explain things to
me that i knew factually were just
incorrect um and so you know there's
there's i think this is a gradual change
but i think we're we're more of like the
at the suddenly point of things for sure
what was going on in the economic or
finance classes in college like did they
have any clue about bitcoin did you ever
ask them about bitcoin were they just
dismissive of it like what was going on
yeah i did i did ask a couple guys a
couple of my economics professors um i
shared like some some of the uh stuff
from plan b like stock to flow uh and i
did ask a couple of my computer uh
science professors i was like hey like
what do you think about this and i got a
business call from from a blockchain uh
company which you know
say what you want about blockchain uh
but i didn't really think they they
understood what was occurring right it
was like oh yeah blockchain technology
is very interesting and um without
realizing that um i don't even like
blockchain to be honest i i prefer time
chain uh when when talking about bitcoin
like you know satoshi solved the
byzantines general's problem and so i
think like the rabaho goes very very
deep with bitcoin and what it solves and
and how big um you know the the of a
problem bitcoin solves it's literally
the total addressable market for bitcoin
is the biggest in the world and so you
know i don't think any of my professors
grasped that it was something that took
me
months or years even um of just like
intense intense studying intense
learning obsessive uh learning right um
the virus is literally spreading um and
so yeah i think it was something that
they didn't really grasp at all which
was just why it was another reason to
kind of leave and just pursue something
else what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]